[Music]
4.4 billion people live in big cities
worldwide myself included and getting
around isn't easy or convenient the
pandemic made the budgetary problems of
urban transit systems even worse
bringing steep declines in ridership
meanwhile the federal government is
providing massive new subsidies for
urban rail systems that barely anyone
used pre-covid like a proposed 2.5
billion dollar streetcar in Atlanta rail
was cutting edge technology in the 19th
century I predict that by 2050 the
standard and urban Mobility will be
electric mopeds and pedal assisted bikes
which is to say individualized forms of
Street Transit powered by apps
throughout much of Asia mopeds have
already become commonplace competing
with cars rickshaws and the lowly
bicycle in providing point-to-point
Mobility which is where rail falls short
some U.S cities have sought to ban
e-scooter companies such as bird Lyman
Rebel but like uber these services are
proving so popular the commuters won't
let them be outlawed